είναι δεν είνι τόσο δυνατών όπως είναι τον πιο παλιο γενιώ εμείς τις έχουμε πελάτες
οι οποί ότι και να γίνει δεν πρόκεεται να φύγουν ποτέ απόυ τις ίτουπώς τις
νέες γιενίες δεν υπάρχει καθόλου αυτό το πραγματι έννεια του λόγι αλτί αλλάζει καθημερινά οπότε
πρέπει να παλέύεις πολύ περισότερον για να κερδίζεις τους πελάτες τις νέας γενιάς δεν πρέπει
αθεωρείς κανένας δεδομένο και πρια χρεσιμοποίας και καινούριες μεθόδους τις οποίες στο παρελθόν ουται κάνν
τις κεφτός είναι πολύ δύσκολο το παιχνδι με τους νέους πελάτες είναι δύσκολοι πελάτες δνα
ηνέι πλύ διαφορειτικ πολύ διαφορικέ και οι πιο παλιές για ίνιες υναι δύσκολες αλλά τις
ξέραμετες δυσκολίες ξέναμε δι έπρεπει να κάνουμε για να κρατήσουμε ευχαριστημένους τους πελάτες τις ιλικίας
μουμε με ένα τις πιο παλιών ιλικιν με τις νέες ιλικίες δεν είναι τα ίδια
πράγματα που θέλουν και κάτι το οποίο μπορεί να εκτιμά οι πιο παλια γενιά να
μην σημαίνει τίποτα τα γαγια την πιο νέα γνιά ο πότε εδώ είναι που πρεαλλάξουμε
εμείς να ξει ας μείν ξεχνάμε ότι φέρνουμε και κόσμο μέσα στη σίρα ο οποίος
πλέον ανοίκι σετούτες τες γενις οπότε μιο εύκολον ο κόσμος που έρχεται στη σίδορνα μας
εμβολιάς ε με νές αξίες και νέους τρόπους διαχείρησις των πελατών επίσης οι νέες γιενιές
θέλουν τεχνολογία εμπολλά σημαντικό δεν θέλουν να μιλούυν στο τηλέφωνο ες θέλεμιλά κανένας θέλουν όλο
να κάνουν πατούν δύοκλεήξει να γίνεται η δουλειά τους οπότε έπρεπε και το κάναμε το
διο υλια σκο ιδιο να δώσουμε πάρα πολλά ψει φιακά εργαλία στους πελάτες να μπορούν
να μηναι να μην χρειαζεεν άρχονται στο κατάστημα να μη χρειαζδο ταβαίρνουν στο εκατόντριανταδύο για
να μιλούν με κάποιο λιτουργό αλλά να κάνουν τη δουλειά τους μετρία κλήξ από τονι